the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
so let's do a really fast estimation to
just make sure you're up to speed on
solar facts so how big a solar panel do
you need to power a hundred watt
incandescent lightbulb does anyone
remember the flux solar flux
yeah doesn't want me to swear it exactly
and efficiency 20% 10 the 20% so to make
it really easy the math let's go with 10
so that would be 100 watts per meter
squared and we have no other
inefficiency losses and we're just going
directly from solar panel to lightbulb
for lighting in the middle of the day
very common need that would be a 1 meter
panel right or 1 meter square panel okay
so I think this solar opt-ins that we
covered last week are sodus and I didn't
have time at the before class but I'll
try to hunt one down during the during
the lab a an example of a sodas bag that
a student invented that's kind of cool
to see
then there's still solar thermal and PV
and so there was a confusion about the
difference between solar thermal and PV
so fundamentally solar thermal is just
using the greenhouse effect to get
something hot and use that heat as
opposed to PV center photovoltaics and
that means you're taking the the photons
from the Sun and converting that using a
semiconductor material that has a photo
voltaic behavior to get the electric
current out from those photons so that
those are quite distinct heat versus
electricity and so solar thermal is
typically used for things like heating
water because it's really easy to keep
the water low relatively easy hit the
water with the Sun and then it's just
direct so here's an example of you have
your panel which is
a Bulbul egg panel but just a panel
where you have a volume of water that's
probably in a box that has black behind
it so you're maximizing your solar
radiation your cold water goes in the
water heats up your hot water comes out
and it goes into your hot water storage
tank there are of course many ways to
make this point much more complicated so
that you get different benefits but that
would be a simple way to think about it
and out in the Mojave Desert
there's a 350 mega watt peak output
solar thermal installation this is a
little complicated because they're using
the hot water which is steam to power a
turbine and that turbine creates
electricity so that's one way of getting
electricity out of solar thermal but its
indirect unlike full Alutiiq so that's
that's the distinction and in terms of
developing world applications I hope I
have some at the end but if not it's
really common to if you want a hot
shower to just have a big bag on your
roof and it keeps up and then you get
hot water for as long as that bag lasts
and then it's cold water again so that's
one example that's common and then I'll
talk about some PV applications in a bit
so I wanted to do a quick overview of
photovoltaics so
basically that looks again the fool will
take effect is being taken advantage of
to generate electricity this says in
silicon there's a lot of different
photovoltaic materials I'll touch base
on really fast there's also confusion
about what this Junction is the junction
is emphasized because on this slide
because it's the where the interesting
stuff happens in the cell but it's just
where the two slightly different layers
of silicon interact generally there's
generally not a special separate
material there though this is
complicated because we're generalizing
and there's a lot of different so a
different silicon and full of I take
materials and different ones behave
differently but generally so I'm just
going to talk about silicon like a
traditional silicon cell because it's
very common and easy so you have silicon
that on the top side has been doped in
such a way that it had that's called
n-type so it means that it attracts more
negative electrons and the bottom side
has been doped the opposite way so
distracting more called p-type for
positive so it's attracting more
positive electrons and so you can
imagine if negative positive you're
creating flow and that's critical
because you need the flow in order to
get the electricity out of the cell so
you can see here you've got your n-type
on top your p-type on thought them
that's the junction where the the
positive electrons are going down the
negative electrons are going up and
we're getting electric flow which is
providing your electricity the light
your light bulb or what
you want yeah so you can sort of think
of this as a diode right because it's
allowing directional flow like we talked
about like a knit light of the light
emitting diode it's just an electricity
emitting diode there's one way maybe if
thinking about it so there's a bunch of
different materials yeah
so the can I remember this the n-type
has more you know what I can't even
remember because it does so it's not
critical there's a difference they flow
does anyone remember okay so the
efficiency is really going to vary
depending on the material and how
carefully it was processed and carefully
translates to cost and the other thing
to remember is that it's dependent on
light normal or perpendicular to the
surface so that's why you have to tilt
your solar panels into the Sun and why
some arrays that are expensive
automatically tilt themselves other way
ones you just put on the house or
wherever you're putting it at the
maximum angle for the most amount of
time but if you don't put it in the
right place or the right angle you're
really going to minimize the efficacy of
the cell someone wanted to know is it
just silicon that's used no silicon is
most popular right now but you can see
there are some other materials some of
which are more experimental than others
and I'm sure there's additional examples
that I don't even have on here but
there's a lot of different materials
used all pros and cons for example
cadmium is pretty toxic if it gets out
but hopefully it doesn't but it's all
challenging so household solar or how
yeah sorry
yeah yeah and exactly so silicon is a
good semiconductor and a semiconductor
means it's not a full conductor like say
a copper wire and it's not a full
insulator like say the plastic around
your copper wire it's somewhat conducts
and that allows you to do cool things
like having the full of okay effect
well they like complete the conductors
don't have a fall will take effect I
think it's a good way to think about it
do disagree
right exactly so there's no later Ichigo
yeah all right thank you for helping me
so the clarification is that the
semiconductor allows you to have create
flow so that when you excite the
electrons of material they have to go
somewhere in order to be useful right
and if it's fully conductive you can't
change how we talked about so this is
doped differently than this so you allow
you have a negative sign a positive side
to a lower flow you couldn't do that in
a full conductor but you can is I mean
okay so
full voltaics is generally wiring a
bunch of solar cells together you guys
wire series I believe but they're
typically wired in series and parallel
I'll get into that in just a sec and
then you can take those panels and wire
them together into big enormous systems
and one of the things to this been
challenging is that they're sensitive to
temperature and so for example in areas
where it's really hot where there's a
lot of Sun that would be a great place
to put a solar panel except they get too
hot and then they get less efficient so
they're really frustrated there were
some questions on series versus parallel
wiring and hopefully this is just a
quick review but if you put two cells in
series the voltage is additive and so we
have two six volt 350 and power
cells you put them together and you're
getting 12 volts where's if you wire
them and parallel the voltage is an
additive the current is and if you put
them in series and parallel which is how
they're commonly wired then you get the
voltage and the current you actually
need ideally however the thing that
always roam is solar cells which
hopefully you'll notice today is that if
you cover one of the panels up that
drops the current in that panel and it
affects all the panels when they're
wired in series and so it's a really
frustrating reality that they all need
to be they all need to be equally clear
so the components of a solar system you
have a panel you have the regulator
which typically has the components
inside it so that you make sure that the
electricity is flowing in just one
direction as we talked about it goes to
some sort of storage and then it goes to
an inverter if you need AC appliances
you can see that all of these different
components have efficiencies so every
single one is going to drop your
it's great to click too many times it's
gonna drop your efficiency which is
really frustrating so again you have rid
tide systems just like we've had
everything else or you have standalone
or you have high hybrid I'm not going to
talk about grid because we don't do that
much in this class but for standalone
systems so you have your charge
controller going to your battery and
then an inverter so just what we talked
about and I just
I don't know why today is going so
poorly but it really is I'm sorry yeah
you would not you would need not only
like some resistance to get the total
resistance right but you'd also need
that inverter
so hypothetically yeah people do all
sorts of bad practices and get away with
it for better or for worse so for
example the battery charger as shown
from Bo Phoenix on Wednesday
literally
a panel with a couple of wires coming
out going into
a place where you can charge your
batteries which means that it has great
possibility for failure but it's really
cheap and so there's always that
trade-off of you can take something and
it'll be super cheap and that's handy
but it won't work very well and you have
to figure out what you want right like
you can make this a ten million dollar
that'd be hard but you know that was in
dollar system or a one dollar system and
there's real trade-offs in terms of
costs and performance well so batteries
only need direct current so they're
getting direct current where is like
this computers expecting alternating
current so I need a special device if I
wanted to use direct current computers
bad example because of the cube that T
actually does take direct current to but
this projector would be too special
device to get direct driver
and so of course you can see extremes
from a stand-alone system in Bangladesh
all the way to a 10 megawatt solar array
so this is at in Abu Dhabi yeah so I
don't want to take the time to go
through this whole question but it'll be
in the lecture notes that I'll post
today so if you and I think I'll post
them in week 4 because this was the
solar lecture that never was but it
makes sense to put in the solar week but
if you can go through it it actually
this actually walks you through if I'd
recommend doing it like we do in class
to try to do it and then if you get
stuck you can go through it but this is
good practice especially because the
homework has been dying out in order to
make sure you guys have enough time to
get all the work done but this is a
helpful calculation to be able to do so
developing world applications just
quickly what do you think people tend to
use solar for in developing countries
water heaters what else
yeah
yeah so TV is asking a lot out of a
solar panel you might see it but it's
going to be expensive and you certainly
wouldn't see like a refrigerator on here
because again that's getting really
expensive in terms of the size of the
panel you need and some examples that
we've talked about but I just wanted to
refresh your memory on so one is Grameen
Shakti in Bangladesh where women and
wire up the solar panels they use
micro-financing to make the panel's
affordable it's they're often in little
markets for people by by little amounts
of food and things like that they can
also access electricity or the market
you just have light on at night and they
also do micro utilities too
I believe there's about a thousand micro
utilities operating in Bangladesh
there's I do not sure how they pronounce
themselves but this group in Brazil and
they do a fee for service where the
company is responsible for the care of
the battery which is critical because
batteries require care and if they're
not well cared for
you can cut their life by half if not
more and they're pretty expensive part
of a system they work on a flexible
payment system so that the customer
decides because some people work in
areas where you might make most of your
money in one month and so if you're
expected to pay month-by-month that can
be really tough but if you can just pay
once a year it works and then they do a
lot of user education to help make sure
people use them effectively and care for
them properly SELCO we also talked about
in India and they have lots of different
examples from lighting in a temple
storing cocoons for silk industry in
houses and market places we talked about
D like design and they have lights that
are come with a solar panel or have the
solar panel integrated into the light so
people have
a light option even if they don't have a
home installation one of the challenges
with solar like this and you'll see it a
lot people have it on their bags or you
can get by a charger that solar panel
that you can put whatever is it requires
you to be outside or it to be outside
and so it's challenging like I was have
a flashlight that has a solar panel on
it and I stopped bringing it on my
fieldwork because I'm not necessarily
outside the whole day and I can't just
leave it there or else it'll walk if I
don't keep an eye on it and that's true
for everyone and so that's one of the
frustrating things about solar generally
is that the panel is expensive and worth
something whether it's integrated into
the device or not and so figuring out
how you keep the panel secure it's easy
to stick a battery inside a secure room
not so easy to stick a panel inside a
secure room that has no roof so that's
challenging and they tend to be small
enough that they're easier to steal than
say it like a wind turbine or something
like that the solar thermal group which
is an MIT project this is an example of
using solar thermal in a developing
country and they have a wide variety of
applications of different ways that they
use the solar thermal but some of which
I think is electricity generating as
well from the steam so that does have a
real-world application
you